margaret ward wrote an article with
business insider talking about the top
five best countries
to raise kids in and top five worst
countries to raise kids in
based on a thousand markers apparently
is what she came up with and
you know you're gonna be surprised on
who's on the top five
worst list but let's go through it
here's some of the things that scored
off
on the uh what places to raise your kids
in one is safety homicide rate number of
school shootings per capita
the other one is cost percentage of net
income that goes towards child care
costs
out-of-pocket health care costs then
it's happiness
world happiness reports survey
inequality score
in the gi and i index ranked by the
world bank then it's health
maternal mortality rate share of
population exposed to air pollution
above uh world health organization
limits then it's education then it's
time meaning
average hours adults work per day as
collected by the oecd paid maternity and
paternity leave okay so these are the
markers
she got it based off of here's the top
five best countries
to raise kids in number five is
luxembourg
number four is finland number three is
sweden
number two is norway shout out to kai's
family his parents did a great job
and number one is iceland iceland josh
so you mean
adam if you're looking to raise your
family you may want to consider iceland
looking now
looking very heavy top five florida
iceland my top top
five worst you're ready top five worse
number five
is bulgaria number four is turkey
okay number three is chile
number two you ready for this united
states
is the second worst place to raise kids
according to margaret ward and number
one is mexico mexico is the worst place
to raise kids
so you got to realize when i get
articles like this and i read them
it really makes me laugh and ask if
margaret wards has
ever lived in any other place
and many times when they do data like
this
you can choose any data you want to have
something work in your favor you can
pull a data out and at the same time
if somebody's bringing data and using
world health organization to say
whatever while the credence the
credibility of world health
organizations been shot
what do you think about somebody writing
an article saying u.s is the second
worst country in the world to raise kids
in
this is i mean i don't have kids so
like i'm just speaking as just like what
are you doing without kids but i do have
an opinion on this tell us but josh has
16 kids what dude what's it been like
raising all those kids
tell me about it let me tell you why i
raised my kids in america and why
margaret is the single-handed least
stupidest person on the face of the
earth
look look pat josh don't get all come on
come on
you were trying not to hold back yes you
want to know why america is great it's
our constitution it's our freedom it's
our people it's our land it's our
it's our economy this is what makes our
country greater let me
uh let me just ask kai back here is
norway having to build a wall
around it to keep people out are people
trying to illegally immigrate
to norway by the millions and millions
and millions
is it called the norway dream now no
offense to norway i'm sure we got a lot
of great people there
but people are trying to come to america
because america is the hotbed of
innovation
it's a place that you can chase your
dream it's the place that you can wake
up
every single morning and know that you
are free it's the place that you can
know that should somebody try to take
away your constitutional rights that you
can get on the phone that you can call a
policeman or even better yet
that you can pull out a shotgun and blow
them away
this is what that's probably the problem
josh here's the deal that last sentence
is probably the problem
you know that we're having here if
you've been if you don't like what i got
to say i got a shotgun with your name on
it but if you've never lived in mexico
if you've never lived in some of these
other countries
i had the opportunity to live in mexico
for a little over 10 months
some of the greatest times some of the
greatest people some of the most
beautiful wonderful humble
and absolutely incredible food there's
nothing like a nice
carne avada taco at about 2 a.m with a
nice pepsi
okay or coke are you up to that late
dude you got to be up at 4am what are
you doing up there question is this
bath bath my long hot bath in the
morning
people in mexico and third world
countries and other places
live in constant fear of the ruling
class
there is a huge disparity between the
people the bottom people
and the people at the top there's caste
systems there's all the like if you want
to talk about equality
for all of these jackasses that
constantly want to talk
about there's no fairness in america and
good like these are nothing but spoiled
little brats because if you want to go
to another country you're going to find
that there is no equality like there is
in america this is the fairest game
in the world and we actually have a
constitution that protects people
so guess what my six beautiful kids get
to get raised in a free country
have an opportunity to become
entrepreneurs have an opportunity to
choose what they do and even choose who
they marry in their life
because in other countries guess what
you don't even choose that in fact over
in
china okay the horrible place if you're
even a girl the chances of you getting
slaughtered
even after you're born aborted or
slaughtered after you're born because
you're born the wrong sex
like dude america is a beautiful place
and the fact that she would
put that on it like we should ship her
to another country trump should revoke
her citizenship
and honestly people should stop reading
that flipping idiot's
work damn shout out to margaret ward
yeah
by the way just so you know who she is
this is who she is you can always tell a
person within five seconds of watching
and looking at their twitter profile
here's the description covering better
capitalism
and diversity and inclusion these are
key words
in the workplace business and saturday
previous today show cnbc
world policy views are my own right and
her last thing she retweeted
was from joe biden i have a great honor
to announce that i've picked kamala hers
and she's
retweeted a bunch of stuff about blm uh
anti-trust
you know anti child care all this stuff
not anti-child care child care
inequality all these things so
which means is this her uh no this is
her that's definitely not her it's her
right here
okay josh you got a shotgun with your
name on it there mark so here's the
thing
by the way the the thing that uh
concerns me that i'm seeing a lot in
journalism and
why are people looking for so many
reasons to say that america sucks
where's the pride in who you are like
let me put it to you this way let me uh
people ask me a question they say what
the hell are you i said look there's
five nationalities and cultures and
countries that mean a lot to me
assyrian because my dad's a syrian i'm a
proudest syrian okay armenian because my
mom's armenian borosian
i'm a proud armenian so i had somebody
from dc the other day that aram
hamparian shout out to him he came and
spoke about what's going on between
armenia
and azerbaijan and talk about armenian
genocide which by the way if you guys
got somebody you want me to bring on
from
azerbaijan i'd love to be able to
interview with that person as well to
give their perspective but i'm assyrian
i'm armenian i was born in iran so if
you look at the painting who do you see
in the middle east
because emotionally that's where i was
born 10 years
i lived in germany for two years at a
refugee camp i had a great time in
germany i loved germany to me it was
they treated me very well and in america
these five things matter to me
i have a very hard time you know how
they say if you sit with somebody
and you interview them okay and after
working with somebody for a month two
months three months six months 12 months
if they always complain about people in
the past that screwed them over
there's one problem there why are you
always getting screwed over that means
i'm the next person you're going to tell
the world that screwed you over
i don't know if that made sense or not
of course so if i'm dating you and you
say
your boyfriend sucked your boyfriend
sucked your boyfriend sucked when my
wife and i dated each other guess what
she said about our exes
and they were actually good guys yeah
situation i'm like oh
cool so it wasn't like oh he sucked oh
he did something because
it's like i'm next if that happens right
so i hired somebody and i decided to do
an investment deal oh let me tell you
this guy i'm like oh this deal doesn't
go right
he's going to go around saying this you
got to be careful with this guy keep it
very close because
this [ __ ] you know it could hit the fan
but very very quickly right so
when you are somebody that went to a
university
provided by america you got your
education here
you've done all this other stuff here
america's taking care of you
you can get out and write an article
like this and you say america america's
the second
worst country in the world to raise kids
how did you become who you became
in a world today when many different
countries a woman cannot have a voice
and in america no one looks at it like
that
i have more women working in my company
in here at the office when you go look
at it what nationality do you see the
most a lot of black women how many how
many
how many black ppc work in here probably
60 60
like it's not like we sit there and we
discriminate this is america the ceo is
from iran my cdo is from
philippines so i have a very when you
and i were speaking i said so
uh where are you from you said well from
uh you know
your father is jewish right okay and you
start talking about the experiences but
you still
went to israel you still represent being
a jew maybe you're not as religious and
all that
but you respect it there's got to be a
level of that so
i love the fact that kai defends norway
i love the fact that ricky aguilar
defends michoacan
i love the fact that george palau
defense cuba and puerto rico
i love the fact when i see people that
i'm working with defend who
i love the fact that when i see people
i'm working with talking about great
capitalists who are african-americans i
love the fact that there is that
i have a very very hard time
respecting people who take shots at
their own country
what it was founded on so this kind of
data that comes out
here's what happens the real question
about this kind of data that she wrote
here the article that came out yesterday
here's a question
how many people does it convert
[Music]